well we've got a big announcement that
you'll see first on cbs this morning i
love when this happens nba superstar
michael jordan
you know where he was this weekend at
nascar but he always finds time to give
back
he's making a 10 million donation to
novant health
to open new health clinics in his
hometown of wilmington that's north
carolina
this comes after he already donated 7
million
back in 2017 to open two clinics in
charlotte
the michael jordan family clinics
provide primary medical care
and mental health services to under
insured or
uninsured communities dr michael hogan
has worked very closely with michael
jordan on his efforts
he told us how the clinics impact the
community
you have a place that's thinking more
about just here's a prescription go take
this medication but
but really pulling in the pieces that
may be
barriers for them to achieve their best
health and live their best quality of
life
michael jordan does so many things
behind the scenes to help this is one of
the
rare occasions where they're letting us
know uh publicly what he's done so bravo
to him yeah
big big bravo because this is such an
important thing for those communities
yeah
a lot of people yeah big gift and it's
targeted in a great way yeah
all right